Speaker 1: Republicans have yet again failed to
elect a speaker of the House despite being poised
to take control and swear in their new elected
members, like Jorge Santos, who has not actually
been sworn in yet, even though he said he was.
We'll get to that later. Despite the endorsement
of the failed former President Donald Trump, Kevin
McCarthy has lost again and again and again. That
makes it six total times. And this exposes, number
one, the complete inability to actually lead and
get things done productively, even in the easiest
of circumstances. Like we have control. Let's pick
a speaker. It exposes increasingly the potentially
dwindling power and prestige to the extent, extent
that there was ever prestige of the MAGA portion
of the Republican Party. And it also raises real
national security questions when you don't have
a speaker. There are national security risks. We
will talk about that later as well. Rolling Stone
reporting McCarthy loses again. Despite nod from
Trump, the House of Representatives has rejected
the California representative for a fourth and
probably not final time on Wednesday, subsequently
rejecting him a fifth time and then a sixth time.
And then the voting set to pick back up again
today. I'm sure by the time you listen to today's
program, we may know more. There may have been
more votes. Now, the despite the nod from Trump is
very interesting. Today's Thursday. Yesterday was
Wednesday. On Tuesday, when the first votes for
McCarthy failed people, NBC News went to Trump and
said, Do you still support McCarthy? And he didn't
respond. Much later on in the day, Trump spoke
to people, presumably checked out what Tucker
Carlson was saying, Sean HANNITY and others. And
then he issued on Wednesday morning the following
Not reluctant, but not exactly the most
ringing endorsement of Kevin McCarthy,
saying on truth, social.
Speaker 2: Truth, essential.
Speaker 1: Quote. Some really good conversations
took place last night. And now and it's now time
for all of our great Republican House members to
vote for Kevin. Close the deal, take the victory
and watch crazy Nancy Pelosi fly back home to a
very broken California, the only speaker in U.S.
history to have lost the House twice. Republicans
do not turn a great triumph into a giant,
embarrassing defeat. It's time to celebrate. You
deserve it. Kevin McCarthy will do a good job.
Maybe even a great job. Just watch. Not exactly
a full throated endorsement, and it appears not
to have quite been enough, not to be quite enough
to get Kevin McCarthy over the finish line. Now,
I wrongly assumed yesterday that it would become
less and less entertaining each time that Kevin
McCarthy lost. Each time that Kevin McCarthy
failed, it has actually become more entertaining
each time because he seems increasingly
exasperated and desperate. Now, at this point,
there are discussions of should Democrats make a
deal with Republicans to vote present rather than
to vote for Hakeem Jeffries, who Democrats have
been completely united behind the idea being or to
abstain from voting altogether. And the idea here
is Democrats aren't going to vote for a Republican
for House speaker. But would Democrats help lower
the threshold from the 218 needed votes lower
so that maybe 212 gets Kevin McCarthy the numbers
that he needs? I don't believe Democrats should
do this. The idea that now it is Democrats who
have to come to the rescue of Republicans because
somewhere between ten and 20 maggots in the House
are holding the speakership hostage, It is not for
Democrats to fix that. Now, I recognize there are
national security risks to not having a speaker,
but that's on Republicans, and I hope that
Democrats don't do that. The counterpoint would
be, are there six Republicans who can be bought
and who would vote for Hakeem Jeffries? Now,
I don't mean a bribe. I don't mean literally take
cash. But what I mean is, are there six reasonable
Republicans in the House who are willing to come
to the table with Democrats and say, listen,
you guys have a mess on your hands. It's a bigger
mess than, you know, whatever Trump is flushing
10 to 15 times or whatever analogy you want to
use. You guys have a mess on your hands. We are
united. And we are ready to govern. And we could
have debt ceiling issues that come up. We could
have a natural disaster that happens, which we
need to respond to. We've not sworn anyone in. We
don't have a speaker. This is a problem. Be part
of the solution. We will be willing to, you know,
bring forward for debate issues of importance
to your whatever a negotiation like adults.
Are there six Republicans willing to do that? I
think the answer is no. But it's worth exploring
that if you are the Democrats before you going to
acquiesce to these absurd demands from people like
Matt Gaetz and others, it's completely and totally
pathetic. So that's what's going on. Six losses
now for Kevin McCarthy, by the way, the record
number of ballots. I believe it's 133 and it was a
very long time ago. So we're nowhere close to the
record. But certainly for the last hundred years,
this is this is a record. So that's where we are
right now. Let's now talk about the explosively
growing civil war within the Republican Party
and the right wing about what's going on